you all may know that i am not
big on talking about wokeness
like i don't use the term seriously i
don't say whoa
that when when i want to say someone's
re really politically and culturally
aware
i talk about issues and i evaluate ideas
individually i don't say that the
person's really woke
i don't really care about whether one
has a certain package of beliefs to
qualify as woke
but as much as the wokeists talk about
being woke
and at this point i don't know that
anybody's really doing it other than
than
sort of ironically the right wing has
developed a real obsession
with wokeness as some kind of dangerous
subculture
of some kind and they love filling air
time
with it but it's gotten so stupid
because
again most of the left isn't even
talking about being woke in a serious
way anymore some do
it's not a really big thing so here is a
painfully cringe-inducing news max
segment
where a guest quizzes the two hosts
on their wokeness and everything about
this
sent chills down my spine for how cringy
it is now
first as a mere technical thing
the entire segment is confusing because
the quiz
answers are put on screen and they're
numbered one
two and three but the guy running the
quiz keeps talking about options a b and
c
like it doesn't match up down to every
detail it's all so stupid and
nonsensical but let's get into this and
see if we can learn anything
about how the right sees supposed
wokeness now
is this a comedy segment i don't know i
don't think so
because newsmax i don't think has any
comedy shows
but with the gut-felt show on fox now
um completely distorting what is and
isn't considered comedy you never really
can tell all right so let's get into the
first segment and i think that this is
not comedy let's look
when i find out how woke both of you are
especially with a really really short
quiz so let's kind of get to it very
quickly and
let's see how woke both of you are so
number one
how do you feel about men spreading a
it's a real problem
b people should give each other space or
c it's complete nonsense
what do you say heather and bob it's
complete it's more than complete
nonsense
it's incomplete nonsense it makes no
sense okay
okay now my answer on that is what they
would call b
or i guess number two people should give
each other space
uh regardless of gender and um
i i you know gender i find myself
extremely annoyed by people who crowd me
when it's not necessary and i don't care
about gender when i was just in aruba
for uh david pakman show spring break in
march
fully vaccinated of course i was waiting
at a restaurant outdoors i did all
outdoor
and i was wearing my mask because the
rules in aruba are
when you approach a restaurant and when
you're being brought to your table even
if the table is outdoors you just wear
your mask and i'm going to do it those
are the rules if i want to travel at
this time i follow the rules okay so i'm
wearing my mask and i'm standing
standing next to my girlfriend and i
really just i looked at the guy and i
knew this was going to be annoying
american guy with no mask he has the
mask over one
ear and it's hanging like it's just
hooked onto one ear
comes and stands right behind me now
when i say right behind me you might say
david you're exaggerating
no no no this guy was so close that when
i did a half turn
just to look at him and sort of say dude
back back
btfo just doing a half turn made it
so that my elbow goes right into this
guy's chest
and i just turn and look at this guy and
he backs up maybe six inches
that has nothing to do with gender i
don't care what bathroom anyone's in
i just give people space i'm sorry
whether it's in a bathroom or man
spreading or whatever um just give
people space that's my view let's
continue on to the second question
so number two should transgender people
be allowed to use the bathroom
of their choosing a i don't feel
comfortable with that b
make all bathrooms gender neutral or c
of course
i'll say number one i don't want to know
that much about you i just want to go in
and use the manager
okay okay okay now i actually start to
get the sense here
that even the hosts are are sort of
virtue signaling and what i mean by that
is
they seem to be picking the answers
that they believe are the correct
anti-woke
answers for the newsmax audience like
i have a hard time imagining that they
really care too much about which
bathrooms people use now i'm a number
two
and three on that or you might call it b
and c
i don't care what bathroom people use i
would like to see gender neutral
bathrooms
singles i guess we call them really
common in europe
that that's where i'm at let's keep
going okay number three
should women be allowed combat roles
in the military a yes women are equal to
men
b but held the same does the same
standards as men or c
no women are weaker i say number two
yeah i'd go with two as long as you're
held to the same stance yeah same
standards but
you can if you can do the job do the job
well uh i now i agree with them here i'm
a two on that or b
and that's been my position on a lot of
these things firefighting military stuff
whatever
if there's a reason why in the job you
need to drag
a hundred and fifty pounds a hundred
yards in under a minute or whatever
then if you can do it you should be
qualified for the job period that is my
view
um i don't think that makes me anti-woke
it might make them more woke than they
even want to believe
all right last segment i was surprised
about the quiz here in a moment number
four should a baker
be forced to make a wedding cake for a
gay couple even though
that they don't agree with gay marriage
a yes b
maybe or c no uh
let's see oh i'm it's easy no i mean
they can find somebody else to make it i
mean
no and i know that that disagrees with
with
law right now there are people paying
fines
uh you know for it but no they shouldn't
be forced
yeah it's a private enterprise for
goodness sake absolutely that's what i
was gonna say for sure
are you cringing yet the female host
actually seemed unsure
what she was supposed to say there so
she lets the guy answer and then jumps
in with yeah
yeah that's what i was that's what i was
going to say now the wording of that
is the wording that the right loves they
love saying should the
anti-gay baker be forced to make a
wedding cake for gay people like a slave
almost and in fact rand paul has talked
about single payer would make doctors
like
slaves that's not the right framing
that's like saying should a racist baker
be
forced to make a cake for a black couple
even if they don't like black people
that's not the right framing
the framing is should it be legal
to discriminate against people on the
basis of race
or on the basis of sexual orientation
that's a more accurate framing they love
that framing that they just gave
it's not the right framing uh okay and
then here's the wrap up
okay all right last but not least do you
think young children
should be given the choice to become
transgendered and receive hormone
treatments a
yes it's their body their choice b wait
until they're adults or c
no no yeah i'd go wait until you're an
adult make whatever decision you want
but that's ludicrous for kids that
they're still developing
psychologically and mentally heather
bob i have to tell you you know what
this is probably one quiz
you're going to be ecstatic about
failing because you are the least woke
people
probably walking so you've got an f on
this
this is truly painful to watch they
don't even realize
or really understand what being woke is
or how the quiz works or really anything
and again a bogus question it's not
about
children having the choice to become
trans trans just means
you have a sense of personal identity
and gender that doesn't match your birth
sex biologically you can't control
whether a kid
is trans that's something that they feel
inside the question is about whether
they should be allowed to do certain
things to have their gender identity
match their sex
they don't even know what it means to be
trans and the question
as is maybe not surprising to you
portrays
a total lack of understanding of what
these issues even are
so there's the quiz i don't know who
passed or who failed or whatever but
a very very painful segment to watch on
newsmax
and it's hard to imagine that uh that is
compelling watching
for too many people that are watching it
unironically